sprachmächtig angucke geht es nicht mehr
du wirst runterfallen
hey leute und willkommen zurück bei t3n
nach diesen epischen fällt grad von oben
runter ich habe mich mit ihm trainieren
ein bisschen raus und ecken springen
hast ja gesehen ich nicht ich guck dir
mal wieder kurz zu wie du das verriegelt
sich das wirtschaften nicht du musst
brauchst shift nebenbei ach so das hab
ich gar nicht genutzt
ich habe noch nie mit schiffen mit chef
gesprungen guck guck dich dass man ja
jetzt gehe jetzt jetzt geht's in
die ganz nah dran die ganze zeit hoch
und runter jubelten auf einmal
kein sprint
ich hab das nenne ich machte musik
geht so ich habe keine ahnung warum das
bei mir nicht funktioniert das ja und
stehen so episch filmen ja und ich mach
das mal film heute mal ich kann ja mal
ein kleines thema anschneiden und zwar
alleine an die branche ihre holen
wäre holen anschneiden
moment wann ritzen anritzen auf dem
anderen arm aber
so darf ich sagen schon einmal ein thema
an unwritten auf dem arm
nun endlich schneider noch weiter
seither habe ich neben mir vom ritzen
noch weiß was du ja
ja ja
so was könnte man dann erzählen kann
ahnungslos schießt los
was haben alles durchgenommen schon der
offenen runter so ist als session was
war es was wir haben schon lieber
freundin
ironie auf youtube in alles mögliche
wir könnten über profis fit man so ein
irgendwie sowas wie sind wir auf 6
plänen bekommen hab ich doch das hat
noch stellen glaubt ich soll mich schon
ein paar mal erzählt bei mir ja mit
deiner webseite ich meine ja genau dinge
sind da ja wie bist du denn drauf
gekommen lass mich nicht mehr sehen also
viel erwarten da ist so eine epische
geschichte wie ah ja ich habe einen pakt
mit dem teufel geschlossen und ich
hoffte nur weiterleben in dem ich mit
let's play anfange nein also langeweile
langeweile ja
osterferien herbstferien war mir ein
bisschen langweilig jetzt letztes jahr
oder das sommerferien ich glaube
irgendwo dazwischen
und ich habe wirklich ich war einfach
auf youtube ich habe davor nur alberto
auf youtube geguckt und die außenseiter
früher waren sie ja noch ganz okay
jedenfalls habe ich sie dann so geguckt
und hab mir dann gedacht und kann er gar
nicht so schwer sein hab ich mir gedacht
material live videos oder was anderes
hab keinen bock mich zu zeigen mache ich
mal lieber ja keine ahnung dann ist mir
halt nichts eingefallen was ich
irgendwie machen könnte von daher habe
ich dann einfach mal auf youtube auf der
startseite immer so ein bisschen vorbei
geguckt was die anderen machen habe dann
let's play es gesehen von bronk
und dann habe ich mir erst mal genug
gedacht let's play wenn du das jetzt
auch des planes ist das bestimmt danach
mache und da wusste ich ja gar nicht
dass das allgemein let's play hast du
die kategorie und das nicht kommt dass
er 100 deswegen habe ich meine ersten
videos quasi so gameplay von demo dem
spiel gameplay minecraft blabla so halt
irgendwie genannt welche ich komme da
einfach gar nicht mehr hoch weiß das ist
ein komplettes problem gerade
also eigentlich wenn eine kurzfassung
ich hatte langeweile und wollt was neues
probieren
ok ja wenn wir ein bisschen seltsam die
story irgendwann auf sumatra stoßen
nachdem ich so angefangen hat und so
cool man kann sich kaum noch gar nicht
mein erster sich schon jetzt plate hat
da gibt es ja auch noch
auch beton
sprint ich weiß net files runter hier
vorher schön hoch aber im weiße so guckt
ihr da so um die ecke rum ja nochmal
club und nicht ohne fanfaren
so machst du mal da so und jetzt soll
hier sprinten ich komme
jetzt beleidigt mich wieder alle alt du
kannst ja gar nichts kann ich gar nicht
ich muss ich echt zu geben weil es ist
viertel vor zwei mitten in der nacht und
ich schaffe nicht mehr den ersten ich
bin einmal ich bin einfach immer gegen
die leiter weise das kommt die
kommentare jetzt nimm doch halt woanders
auf warum der mitten in der nacht denn
wir sind ja eigentlich machen wir sind
ja eigentlich relativ fach und wer ich
hatte gerade einfach bock auf aufnehmen
ich bin da ganz auf der höhe seiner
schaffenskraft
ich guck mal kurz weiter wie wir das
hier noch geht also jetzt noch 13 7
jetzt 13 8
das ist leider anders halt blöd das
problem
diese partie ist blöd
grad moment
jetzt noch 13 9
nunmehr ist das nicht 13 10
die mögen ja dann vielleicht einfacher
sein ist nur diese leiter geschichte
gerade die so ziemlich leer und warum
geht das ja ich weiß warum ich habe
meine hunger anzeige ist weg ich habe
auch voll gemacht haben 100 zeitlich
gesehen ich würde mich als auch nicht
sprinten kann
würde muss mal kurz die äpfel essen hamm
mein gott ich wäre übrigens fast
gestorben ist mir aufgefallen hh so
jetzt aber jetzt aber ich hab gedacht
kann doch nicht wahr sein jetzt sorry
allerdings lasten einem run durchgemacht
am besten noch im januar dich nicht oben
bin und ich kann nur sagen jetzt geht
noch bis 10 das heißt dass jetzt gerade
sechster damit sie macht 19 noch machen
dann haben wir auch schon stufe 13 dann
ist nur noch drei andere stufen wo ich
darf ja nicht mehr den ersten job weiß
nicht
soll guck dir das mal guckt sich das mal
an es
gibt da komm ich die ski pass auf was
auch so gemacht die schrift nicht
nach vorne gucken nach links dann durchs
widerspricht nach vorne gucken links das
schiff
also von der wand weg springen in der
luft nach links drehen guck ich war kurz
darauf habe ich doch gesagt jetzt noch
platz da hier mögen mich mal hier jetzt
hier
war nicht so toll ja jetzt sagt jetzt
sagt jetzt sagt ja klar ich
wahrscheinlich darauf machte
so
ein
platz spark auf höhen
wenn ich heute an einen kommentar
geschrieben ist das paar kauft ihn ist
das parkett doch der schweiß oder unter
der blitz war christa funke
der funke des filmes hoeneß ja nicht für
mich sondern des 5
frauen sind natürlich keine menschen
marin
kam aber lieblingsfilme reden
lieblingsfilme
fertig ich bin mir so fantasy richtung
chroniken von narnia 2 fand ich ganz
guten 1 der dritte war irgendwie scheiße
falls du kennst ich habe nur einen von
den dreien gesehen aber ich weiß nicht
mehr welcher da wurde in den schrank
gegangen sind es war der erste ja dann
habe ich den gesehen der war aber noch
ganz okay eigentlich ja das ist gut mein
lieblingsfilm ist eigentlich ich finde
ich fand das social network ganz gut
hab es bald geschafft
guckst du mir das mal mächtig angucke
geht es nicht mehr du wirst runterfallen
nein
das war der fall nein
welche minute war als minute 8 wird man
merken
ist in drücke natürlich
auch machst du ich hab das nicht tut mir
leid leute aber ich bin einfach zu blöd
für diesen ersten sprung in die
kommentare schreiben ich selber ein
ja
okay ich kriege noch halbwegs sind mal
kurz vor schluss kurz vor dem final
jetzt wo ich wieder
ja du idiot
so hatte so
jetzt stell mich doch runter es könne
nicht angehen
ich lasse es einfach komplett
achteinhalb minuten nur hier um
gestanden den bisher
und hierzu geguckt habe ja ja der
interessantesten folgen er war muss ich
sagen und ich konnte bei der menge
trinken
was wiederum ein vorteil ist
nicht dass du noch ganz dehydriert am
ende vom pc sitzt schon zusammen klappt
wie eine primel wie eine primel schaffst
das bike ist doch total einfach sollte
erst mal klären oh ja so etwa das meinst
du sollte ich das auch erklärt bin ja
lehrer ja stimmt welches fach eigentlich
minecraft
technik dunkle magie
günstige verteilen gegen die dunklen
künste genau
ausrasten com hier
macht man auf das echt böse böse wollen
wir dass wir was springen oder so weil
das ist fies hier wenn wenn ihr sonst
glaubt zieht euch die map und nacht das
oder besser noch was auf video antwort
unter dieses video am besten genau wie
ihr das macht
ihr darüber springt macht es einfach
bevor ihr meckert macht selber genau
selber hier gerade welche stage ist das
welche stage 13 6 kommen hier rein jetzt
3 c level 6 ein versuch noch kommt
da
und vor allem natürlich nicht das beste
raus schneiden sie ist wenn er 20
stunden dran hängt
sondern ja okay sagt am besten auch
wieder gebraucht hat unter dieses video
dann sagen sie ja erst noch versuche ich
muss erstmal ziel noch angeben du kannst
übrigens auch einfach durch die tür
gehen sagen ach so und
so und hier ist die leiter wo ich immer
sagen
na da und da muss drauf springen ja
sehr richtig böse du das ist jetzt alles
böse
man kann doch heute also tor ist ich
wollte tour ist ja vielleicht ist
einfach nur die stage kacke das heißt
der typ der das gemacht hat haben alles
übertreiben kurz fast drauf ich glaube
es ist nicht ohnehin stage 13 und nichts
dagegen auch immer fällt halt drauf aber
ich glaube ich hab's gestartet ja
das ist ja alles jetzt ist guck dir mal
die leider ist es ja noch mal so da
fällt es ganz runter ein bisschen ganz
am arsch jetzt doch nicht schaffen
zu dieser station grad jetzt zwei
spieler halt drauf immer dieses stage
ist in der stage zum beispiel im
untergrund weiter extrem gut
die war ja noch einfach moment warte ich
darauf auch also ich bin jetzt hier um
draufzahlen jetzt guck mal aber die
leiter ist nein weil jetzt ein schiff zu
drücken nein mein bein
ist so fein
a
night baby wie ein fast drauf
denn darauf nein als mir doch mal runter
ich bin einfach gesprungen ohne dass sie
erwartet hatte dass du es schaffst
so jetzt aber ich war schon wieder drauf
hatten wir wieder mit einem mentalen
kräfte oder geschubst in sinntal treffen
ich gehe gerade echt immer drauf
schwerkraft
du musst dich in der luft schon umdrehen
ja mach ich ja es stimmt schon wieder
drauf aber ich schaffe es aber den
sprung um die ecke nicht das ist
irgendwie komisch
ich wieder draußen
ich auch guck mal ich bin dollar
gefallen den sprung in die ecke der geht
ihr nachwuchs habe
mir du kannst ja noch ein bisschen
richtig aufnahme und zwar auf die
aufnahme und
rassen furchtbar aber
ich muss sagen nach t13 es wird so was
von gut ausgerüstet für anderen apps
jedenfalls aber muss bedenken jedes
jetzt die echt schwere challenge das
können uns nicht erzählen
die englisch so die hälfte des
partiellen wir uns einfach nochmal
rechtfertigen
ist weil weil wir schon eure kommentare
jahren können hier seid so schlecht
lasst uns doch mal das kommt auf den
unterhaltungswert aber nicht wie gut wir
sind
drüben ist auch richtig böse richtig
böse willst das packen
natürlich kriegt man das alles hin zeit
überlegt mal werden die zähne aufnahme
sodann gab
fast raufen
nein
ich würde sagen auf den ersten punkt zu
kommen ist noch machbar also ist jetzt
nicht so schwer es geht noch
aber danach auf den zweiten muss
bedenken erster com ist wahrscheinlich
geht vielleicht 14 und 15 1 und 10 in
solchen fällen jetzigen leiter gewesen
dann noch auf die zwei zu kommen ist
eine mathematische katastrophe kann so
gar nicht wie recht denn die
wahrscheinlichkeit ja ja theoretisch
kannst du alles berechnen erste chance
von einst rund ein zehntel das nächste
hast vielleicht eine von 15 15 und so
rechnen dass es einen run einmal
komplett durch schaust ich glaube auch
das erste zu kommen ist bei mir gerade
25 prozent
dass wir jedem vierten mal schaffte auch
video zu kommen dass wir nämlich genau
jetzt der fall und ich bin oben
und ich bin auf den nächsten weiter
auf den nächsten auch los jetzt mach das
ja ich habe einen
checkpoint
jetzt nicht so eine leiter scheiße diese
verdammten wort
scheiße hersteller guck mal wo ich bin
ja bringt mir aber gar nichts muss
zurück
malta da ist man soweit und dann springt
man falsch weil das schafft man es mal
und da springt man falsch ach übrigens
der map der part des verwalters der
folge bei spark auf dem kanal morgen wir
sehen zunächst mal schütteln